all right good morning everyone
so this morning we have a round table
discussion
moderated by jack reynolds that will be
our chance to synthesize some of the
ideas that have come out over the
fantastic panel discussions over the
last couple of days
and also look forward and think together
about the future of our field
this is going to be fun having a round
table with five wonderful directors who
i know and respect so much but i just
want to offer a couple of observations
myself before i ask them to come up and
i'm going to address five questions one
to each of them and then we're just
going to quite quickly after they
respond individually to those questions
we're just going to open it up so many
of you in the audience i'm sure have
much to say and on your mind at this
point but i've been thinking about this
whole theme of sharing that's you know
part of our title of this whole
conference and and for whatever reason
over the last couple days uh an earlier
point in my life keeps sort of bouncing
into my mind which was in 1983 when i
first went to washington to run the
direct the washington project for the
arts and artist organization and for the
first time i had to think about raising
money and you know making a payroll
doing all of that a friend gave me a
book that came out that year called the
gift and it was creativity in the artist
in the modern world and it was authored
by louis hyde some of you may have read
this book some of you may not but the
first chapter was a
talks about the notion of how native
americans back in the early part of
american history would get together and
sometimes offer
gifts
to their new you know immigrants who'd
come ashore
and often when these gifts were given at
some point the native americans would
come back and ask for these things back
and the puritans were very confused by
this and it
generated a term called
indian giver
which was not a very nice term as many
of you know in our cultures but the
thing that hyde brings out in that first
chapter was that the indians had a
different notion about what a gift was
that it was something that circulated
and traveled and never belonged solely
to one
person
and that's i think something that many
of us are dealing with and how we're
thinking about passing on knowledge
sharing our collection and so forth it's
certainly been on my mind as i've
watched this wonderful panel yesterday
with the students who are talking about
their experience of the you know
curating the uh contemporary south
african art show it comes to mind when i
think of john walsh who's come back and
given the gift of his knowledge to the
school it meant so much to him
it's been very evident to me and the
jazz live shows that was curated by
students upstairs both musicians
and also
photography students
and those people have again been
lovingly mentored by moline theodore and
kate ezra
and but over and over again they've
shown the ability to bring forth
knowledge themselves and share it with
others and that tradition is extremely
rich in the world of jazz where
musicians have always felt the duty to
train the next generation so just
thinking finally even on my personal
terms the little show of california art
upstairs
uh the five california artists uh
bischoff
demon corn nary park and tebow i have to
say two of those great artists were
teachers of mine and meant a great deal
to me
and amongst that group three of those
great artists were teachers to each
other or to their colleagues so we're
really dealing in a realm where i think
all of us are interested in this notion
of sharing knowledge passing it on
and the last thing i'll say about
collections i never planned to be a
museum director and it was very shocking
to me when i went back to andover in
1989 to look at the collection that
influenced me so much as a teenager and
all of a sudden i realized out of 12 000
works many of them were in the basement
often never seen you know often never
really put in play made truly accessible
and it raised the question what does it
mean to own this stuff or just say you
have it as opposed to really putting it
in play and keeping it in motion in the
way
uh you know hyde wrote so eloquently
about the native american concept of
gift circulation of a gift economy so
think about that as we want to continue
our work together think about that as i
now bring these wonderful colleagues up
to the table with me
now i don't think this one i'm going to
go into their bali and their bios but we
have michael taylor from the hood art
museum here we have tina olson from the
williams college museum of art we have
sharon corwin from the colby museum of
art we have tom lentz from the harvard
art museum and simone wichit from the
blanton at the university of texas so
please come up and join me at the table
so
so michael i'm um
in the wake of us all feeling great
gratitude to you and your colleagues for
having organized such a great conference
last year at dartmouth and which is
really the model for much of what's
happened here in the last three days the
first question i'm going to direct you
is this college and university art
museums not only actively care for and
manage their collections they also have
a major responsibility to serve their
students and faculty how they do so has
been involved been evolving dynamically
in recent years leading many of us
assembled here today to conceive of our
teaching museums of places where
students are invited to work alongside
us and are offered multiple
opportunities to directly engage
original works of art and then
capitalize do something with them
how do we think this evident expansion
of our artistic and educational mission
might best continue and what priorities
are you setting forth at dartmouth to
help expand a liberal arts education
with a broader range of acting active
learning opportunities
great thanks john
a minor question
well first of all i want to commend you
and pam and everyone at yale for such a
terrific conference
you know there's so many rich takeaways
i can't wait to get back to hanover and
talk with my staff about what they've
learned and how they're going to
implement it going forward
um it's really been a rich dialogue um
i think it is that's a crucial question
and and one of the things i think about
is that
we've really got our mission
right and as a field the teaching museum
field has really
realized that we're not just
museums that teach we are teaching
museums that teaching is at the heart of
what we do it it is sort of part of the
fiber of our institutions every it
permeates every poor
and i could have kissed martha tedeschi
when she said the art and shoot
chicago's a teaching museum because i
think that shows a tremendous shift
because i think there was a a sort of um
a break between it was like teaching is
it that should be on a college or a
university campus and not in a
mainstream civic museum well the fact of
the matter is is that if you look at the
founding documents of any art museum in
this country you'll probably find the
word education in there and and we've we
as i feel we've come back to that
and i think it's so exciting and none of
us have
the answer to how you engage with
students and get them excited with art
and how you bring your faculty in i
think we're all
using shared practices and learning from
each other and every year brings new
challenges and new opportunities but i
just think that that baseline is we know
what what we're in the business of
and and that helps us navigate going
forward
i think that um
in terms of of
you know this this sort of
question that you're posing
we have to
be careful not to repeat the mistakes of
the past
and i think that while we've got our
sense of purpose and shared mission
right
i worry a little bit about the teaching
museum in the digital age and are we
in danger
of um missing an opportunity here and
and let me explain what i mean i think
that
in a way
the
we're going to face online learning i
think online learning is coming
and even though these moocs are not
having great results right now they're
going to improve
and it might be in the future that our
students are actually living in india
and living in south africa
and if we are saying that you are going
to have a great experience when you come
here we're going to teach you how to
learn with objects and and give you
these transformative experiences
what do we do when
the experience is mediated through
technology rather than
the student being right in front of the
work of art and so what i'm hoping as a
field is we start to take that seriously
and one of the things i've loved about
this conference is so many of the
presentations were personal they were
personal story your story just now was
personal about you that something
happened to you
and i think that makes for a compelling
story and and i think as a field we're
doing a great job of telling our story
about what it is that's important to us
so one of my stories is that um as an
any inner city kid growing up in london
i didn't have many experiences with with
art as a teenager but one of the things
i do remember was the open university
and it was on the bbc and i would see tj
clark
and these were old films so he was
dressed in flares and long hair
and he was talking about housemanization
of paris and he was talking about
mayonnaise olympia and i didn't see
mayonnaise olympia until
you know five years later but i was
ready for it because of those
experiences so i want us to think about
web-based learning i want us to think
about you know we know that when we get
the students in front of the work
we can have the john walsh moment we can
we can really get them excited you know
jo you have this wonderful expression
where you go like that i'm
hooking them
and and and great great works of art do
that you you just hook the student if
you if
you know if you if you get a group of
students and you're looking at rembrandt
prince you just see it you see that this
kind of excitement
so i think i i just want us as a field
to not feel like
you know
there was a discussion the other day
about um you know if students
or young people are looking at art and
and they're not
seeing the art they're actually doing
selfies well i think we have to
understand why they're doing that and
what it is
in the digital age that that is changing
behavior and not shut that out and and
say that's different and we're and and
we believe in what we believe so we're
just not going to understand that we
have to really embrace
the these new forms of technology and i
love that student panel last night that
was extraordinary because straight away
they talked about the flickr account and
they're harnessing the tools available
to them
for the purpose of curating
and they're leading the way so so as
i've always said john you know what we
do is
it's all about letting go right now
and how far are we comfortable in
letting go and that's why i asked that
question about the press release
because you're letting them write the
press release i think that is
extraordinary so i hope that helps
thank you very much
you know i have to tell you not too many
years ago a student here asked me what
is a typewriter mr reynolds
we had one ibm selectic at the time
and you know it goes to the point that
you know they literally in the last 20
years things have changed dramatically i
took him to his laptop and said you know
it's this thing that says return and tab
and there used to be this mechanical
thing there was a ribbon and it was red
and black and he's looking at me like
you know what are you talking about
you know
so
well listen you know the two of you and
now i'm going to turn to tina we're
involved in our wonderful collection
sharing where we literally uh you know
asked you know both colleagues is in the
curatorial educational rights and
faculty to come and think about what you
would borrow to
teach courses or of course that
otherwise might not be possible so tina
my next question is directed to you
since again expanding a shared vision is
the major theme of this conference
and we've chosen to help guide the
panels and programs offered with that in
mind what ideas have been coming to your
mind at williams and as to how our field
of teaching museums might better support
one another beyond the mayor sharing of
our collections you know it's a little
bit of a follow-up philadelphia yeah
um thank you jack and thank you
pam and jock and everybody have to
second all of that for what a great
couple days this is this is too close is
it getting
echo back
i love where you started i love that you
began with the lewis hyde example and i
think it's a really really
it's a great way to um
kind of open up our paradigms up i think
what happens always in institutions and
in disciplines is that you get
you get one notion of how things work
and the notion that we have so much of
us is that objects belong to us and then
objects
travel for exhibitions and that's the
structure in which they do that and i
think what was so great about the
collection sharing initiative was really
that it pushed our pushed open our
thinking
and we began to imagine that
collections could move and travel for
all kinds of reasons that were much
broader than a very specific discrete
exhibition
and i know that there were lots and lots
of museums that did really imaginative
things
as part of that initiative what wycma
did was bring in a whole range of
objects that really amplified the
permanent collection installations and
they did that working really closely
with faculty so we had this whole kind
of sudden
um
enlivening of our collection and the
collection was suddenly bit both bigger
and deeper and put in use in this very
um
hyde-like way native american gift
exchange kind of way
so
building on that i think there's
incredible
opportunity to borrow
objects
for curricular and study uses
to simply have objects moving around
for gaps or for particular courses or
for particular
student uses
and do that in a you know it back to the
idea of being agile and nimble we keep
talking about that i think it's going to
come up throughout this morning in terms
of in terms of all kinds of things but
you know how do we
make ourselves nimble enough to both
protect objects and to more easily
have things moving around and have
things moving around outside of an
exhibition that might take a year or two
or three to put together so i think
that's one
big thing to think about and then once
they do move
they gain so much right like we've been
talking over the last few days a couple
people have brought up this idea that
the object has this long social
intellectual life and that it accretes
meaning and we know that that's true we
especially know that that's true in
museums like ours
so how do you what do you do with that
right if an object moves to a new place
and then has a whole new context and a
whole new set of students and eyes
looking at it
how do we make use of that or new
conservation information that comes with
it when it moves and how do we keep that
alive and moving between institutions
i'd say that's one other another kind of
layer
of that like movement of objects
and then i think the third
the third is to think about really
strategic ways
in which we might collaborate on things
that we otherwise just can't do so
for example and sharon might you might
you might follow up on this
but uh the deputy director for
curatorial affairs at wikma lisa doran
who is here in the audience somewhere
and sharon and others have begun to
really brainstorm and think about how we
might share new media and video work
work that otherwise we can't
singly do or at least a lot of us can't
and share the you know the the technical
apparatus that goes along with that
share equipment so you know how can we
do better together collectively what we
can't do alone in terms of objects
and then i think it's i think it's
really building on i think there's lots
of opportunity to really build on
experiences like these in which there's
so much
knowledge and expertise in among us
and we come together once a year and we
learn a lot and that's great but there's
all kinds of ways that we could be
sharing around professional development
i mean those could be very structured or
they could be very ad hoc we could have
you know we could recognize that certain
institutions are really really good at
certain things yale's really really
really good at gallery teaching you know
can
certain museums embed folks you know
just you know here come to my museum and
spend a week and you can learn about how
we run our curatorial meetings it
doesn't have to be big could be big but
it could also be really small something
really really really like a very
particular skill
i think that's something that we can
kind of uniquely do because we have very
overlapping sets of
of skills and expertise that we're
looking to strengthen um
so
so i think it's around objects i think
it's around ideas
and i think it's i think it could be
around skill strengthening professional
development
and that's just you know then we should
hear from everybody else right great
well thank you tina sharon um
my next question is addressed to you and
it's that many of us attending this
conference work at museums that collect
contemporary art and thus provide us
with opportunities to invite living
artists to participate actively with us
our students and faculty members
one of us on this panel you is a
director of a campus museum where an
entire new wing has been devoted to the
work of alex katz others of us have been
collecting the work of selected living
artists in great depth what are some of
the advantages and challenges of doing
that right well thank you jacques and
thank you pam again for the invitation
to be part of this and for such a
stimulating
and exciting conference building on your
conference last year michael this is
really a great continuation of that
conversation
and i think it's you're really asking
what is the role of contemporary art in
the college art museum the university
art museum which i think is something
we've touched upon throughout the last
two days and
i think that's something we
think a lot about as part of our mission
what is our responsibility to the living
artist what is our responsibility
to our audiences in terms of presenting
contemporary art and interpreting it we
know from the focus groups we do with
students that they're that's what
they're interested in they want to see
new media they want to see
contemporary artists at work they want
to hear from them um and i think what we
have found by collecting an artist um
not just alex cass we have the complete
print archive of terry winters we have a
very deep holdings in richard sarah
prince and solo wit
um but in alex katz's work in particular
which as you point out we have an entire
wing devoted to it over 800 works of his
so real depth i mean 800 works offers
you a real view onto an artist practice
is in many ways what that can offer
students as
instruction on process
and
i think what you get to see when you
look at an artist's work in that kind of
depth with that kind of breadth is
really an artist working out
experimenting
oftentimes failing
sometimes succeeding often succeeding
and i think that can be really
instructive we we actually teach a
writing course in the museum as part of
the writing curriculum at colby
and one of the points we try to make is
this this point um in the the lesson of
revision and iteration and i think when
you can show a student
the length of a practice in a process
and that it doesn't just happen you
don't wake up in the morning and then in
the evening have your product your paper
or you start in the evening and you have
it in the morning as is often the case
with undergraduates
but that
that artistic process
creative process writing process takes
real work and it takes iteration it
takes revision we um
this is related to to that point we when
we were doing our expansion project we
did an exhibition of um the
architectural concepts and design that
went into that building and the
architects instead of presenting final
plans for that building presented the
concept and design and process that went
into making it
and we actually brought the writing
students down to share that exhibition
with them and you could see the
architects they were working out through
the models they had six different models
until they got to almost the final one
and you could kind of see the light
bulbs going off it's like that's what it
takes it's you know it's an iteration
and um
so i i i guess my point was that goes
back to that as a lesson that can be
learned through real depth of practice
um i also you know i think one of the
one of the challenges is to how do you
how do you contextualize contemporary
art within your larger historical
collections and that's something that we
have begun to try and think about more
creatively
to not just sequester the contemporary
art of its own galleries but are there
places where you can integrate
contemporary art with your historical
collections
in ways that might be instructive for
both the historical work of art and the
contemporary work of art we recently did
a thematic hang of our permanent
collection
and
we're looking at the
the subject of childhood so we had a
dadwood bay photograph of a young child
on a bike and
a copley portrait of a young girl and
there was something really great about
putting those two works together so um
thinking again about contemporary art
in dialogue with with its history um
drawing upon it and then um having
historical works inflected by
contemporary practices i also think
quite instructive and
and it's um it's sometimes where you get
that hook for the student you know the
copley uh you know you see the students
glazing over copley is great all you
americanists out there
but um but when they can see copley
through a dalwood bay they they have a
different avenue in which i think can be
really
eye-opening and instructive yeah
great thank you so much
tom i'm going to turn to you next with a
question all of us participating in this
roundtable conversation are working at
museums that either recently finished a
major facilities and or reinstallation
project or in the midst of completing or
planning one
what new facilities within your harvard
art museums are deemed to be essential
additions specifically created to expand
the capacities your educational mission
and how are you working to ensure that
these facilities will be sufficiently
staffed and funded well into the future
can i
can i just say i'm really tired of
talking about the building after 10
years
i feel your pain
i know you do
um i'll just start off with the ritual
thanks jack to you and pam for bringing
us all together and um
like everyone else up on this panel i've
been quietly stealing ideas left and
right
but i just wanted to say something i
think i said you earlier which was
the panels have been terrific but what i
found especially moving yesterday was
the student panel to see
young people empowered like that and
motivated in very powerful ways that was
uh quite moving i thought so
i just wanted to say uh thank you for
bringing all of them together for us
um
in response to your question um we're
like everybody else we have
a specific set of circumstances we have
our own needs and requirements um
we've been at this at the harvard art
museums now for about 10 years and we
have literally taken everything apart
physically structurally operationally
conceptually
we've we've tried to think long and hard
about what we can contribute not simply
to the university but to the greater
boston community
this is a little bit different from new
haven but
in boston we actually inhabit
we're part of a very rich complex museum
ecology and harvard itself also has i
think nine other separate museums so we
have to take all of that into account
we spent probably before we even
embarked on this building project i
think we spent close to two years just
essentially pulling over to the side of
the road and thinking long and hard
about what we want to do what we can
contribute how will we do it
and obviously out of that process
everything involves students faculty the
community
but there were i think three sort of
simple to my mind goals that came out of
that process and one was to make our
collections far more accessible than
they've ever been in the past
we also wanted to put them to work for
all students faculty
and the community not simply the
specialists we always have and always
will train
and third and perhaps most important we
wanted to do all of this with models
mechanisms strategies that actually
encouraged collaboration working across
different fields and disciplines and
ultimately
using our collections in more
imaginative ways
i sort of joked about i'm tired about
talking about the building which is
actually true but um i look forward to
the day when we don't have to talk about
the building when we talk about what
actually takes place in the building
with our collections
as i said we all have different needs we
have different circumstances uh both
historical and and current um
we have uh put in place what we think
are a number of rather distinctive
platforms
perhaps the most distinctive is
something we call the art study center
we've dedicated about 5 000 square feet
at the top of our new building
to this idea and it's not a new idea
it's uh
it's the idea that in many ways loops
back to historically what has been
important to us as an institution and
that is a kind of almost religious
belief in the power of original works of
art
as teaching instruments
notwithstanding the role of technology
that we will obviously
not only accommodate but embrace
and the other is
the power of the value of sustained
close looking and observation those are
in our dna they're part of our our
history
um
so this art study center in many ways
loops back to those ideas
it's simply a physical space a physical
arena where under close supervision
students faculty classes even members of
the public can come and request a work
of art and have a very different
experience
than walking through the galleries or
sitting in a classroom looking at power
points or slides
we're not saying it's better than those
other experiences but we know that
people behave differently in those
spaces we actually did a study with
project zero which is the research arm
of the
harvard graduate school of education and
i'll spare you all the mind-numbing
details but they basically said what
takes place in a study center is what we
call high-end cognition it is the gold
standard in terms of learning it is less
mediated is more participatory
it's more physical it's more tangible
and
we knew that already in many ways we
know that in study centers people look
longer they look differently they tend
to look more deeply
and uh
so in a sense it's almost a kind of art
on demand model for us and it's in many
ways a kind of opposing
model from open storage
but it's something that
we think is important for our future we
also have
three one thousand square foot
curricular galleries these are galleries
installed in concert with faculty for
faculty and student purposes
we have something called the lightbox
gallery that sits right at the top of
our facility it's a public gallery it's
a space for new media for digital
technology
we're actually working with something
called the meta lab at harvard which is
it's a kind of teaching and research
unit that is dedicated to advancing
network culture through the arts and
humanities and they have something
called the digital problem solving
initiative so they've actually assigned
to us a team of
graduate students i think from
the graduate school of design from
computer science and they will help us
program that space
we also have something called the
materials lab
it's probably the same thing here at
yale or any other university campus but
at harvard now there is huge interest in
what they now term material
ingenuity the properties the potentials
the limitations of physical materials
and
to our great delight and surprise
many parts of the campus look to
the art museums and their collections
because as we all know artists are
historically great innovators they like
to do things with unusual materials
and so all of a sudden we have people
like marine biology and i didn't know
harvard had marine biology and
the engineering school very interested
in works of art for reasons of structure
or surface or
you know other elements
these these will be spaces that one in
particular where visiting artists
curators conservators faculty students
get together to explore these issues
we also
i should also include in this
overly long response to your question
our conservation laboratory we have the
oldest art museum research training
conservation facility in the country
it's a big part of our operation
and they actually sit at the top of our
building and i've
unfortunately or maybe fortunately
worked at a lot of different museums but
i've never seen a museum where
conservation conservation science and
curatorial practice are so closely
interwoven together so i don't think
it's any accident that conservation sits
right at the top of our program right in
the center of our program and we want to
in a sense double down on that strength
that we have
and i'll just conclude by saying these
physical spaces are wonderful that's
great we think we can do interesting
things we think they'll be engines for
collaboration but
in some ways the most significant thing
we've done with our physical facilities
is change our staff structure
because our old staff structure
would simply not fit into this new model
it would essentially be like putting a
square peg into a round hole so we
fundamentally reorganized our curatorial
staff to encourage more collaborative
work more cross-fertilization
more focused work and we also created
something new called academic and public
programs and obviously we looked very
closely at what yale had done
but this is a new department for us it
essentially replaces our education
department and we made what we thought
was an important decision up front which
was not to make it a sidebar not to put
it over to the side
but it's actually part of our curatorial
division and they work closely with our
curatorial staff to essentially put
together interpretive strategies for the
museum how we're going to use the
collections wonderful and that's the
last thing i'll say about the building
forever great
thank you thank you so much tom and it's
the perfect segue the end of your talk
to the question i want to address to
simone on behalf of all of us
and here it goes simone i think we all
know that the recruitment hiring and
support of excellent colleagues is
ultimately the most important
responsibility of a museum director
i think we also believe that those of us
leading museums now need to strive to be
deaf what i call curators of people not
just able organize organizers of
exhibitions
grand acquisitors of art and aggregators
of knowledge could you state some of the
criteria
you bring to hiring new members of your
staff because you're clearly doing a
remarkable job in that regard and are
there specific competencies you seek and
require for those
who will be working closely with you
your students faculty members and
professional museum colleagues within
such an acting teaching environment as
you now have at the blanton
i'm thrilled to answer the question and
jacques thank you
as well for inviting us here and pam for
organizing this and i'm really proud
that there's so many ut students and
faculty here and for inviting us also
i do think it is an incredibly important
role for the director i see my job and
perhaps it's from kind of my experience
as
creating the environment for good work
to happen that's my principal role
in doing that i'm also very aware that i
need to have the people that i think
have the capacity to do where i want the
museum to go and
i had a bit of a luxury of building a
team
for the next phase of the museum and
i'll talk a little bit about kind of
what i was looking for in building that
team but i don't think it really has
specifically to do with just you know
while i have that luxury building a
group of people to work very closely
with me it's probably something i've
carried forward always in looking at
teams
obviously they need to be a good fit to
where i think the museum needed to go
and i also think that there's kind of a
motivation and
desire if you're going to work at the
blanton specifically and i'm sure at any
institution that that
institutional desire to help build
something
the museum has two
kind of fundamental purposes in my view
is
we have the works of art and caring for
the works of art um and we have the
people whose lives we're trying to
transform
but it's the engine um the heart of the
institution are the people who are there
and it is how you create your identity
it's how you get to where you're going
um and to me that is the most
distinctive part of any institution are
its people
for me intellectual curiosity kind of
what made people qualify
is something i look at very seriously
and intellectual curiosity goes beyond
art history
that art history knowledge was vital if
they're going to be the people
developing programs developing
exhibitions working with our students
but kind of broader curacao about the
world even a finger pulse on
contemporary culture is important
intellectual rigor is something that
also mattered deeply to me i'm a very
rigorous person and i like to be in a
room with everybody a lot smarter than i
am
and
the
kind of for our curators and our senior
educators for the museum specifically
wanting to make sure that we are on a
national platform and by that it's not
just that we're having an impact but
we're also kind of learning from is that
they actually be out in an international
national network of people and i can't
underestimate that especially when
you're in a place
like texas that there be that connection
those are kind of basic qualities of
you know
capacity but i'd say perhaps what is
even more important to me is
the
kind of manner or style of an individual
those are kind of baseline those are
that that was a necessity
for me
one of the things i would listen for
very carefully and i always listen for
very carefully is that people care
deeply about audiences and they care
deeply about education
and education to me doesn't necessarily
mean
just talking about something and
assuming someone else is going to pick
it up
it means actually caring about an
individual
mentoring in a very deep way
and i think that comes from a kindness
and a generosity
so that generosity of spirit is
something that's incredibly important to
me it's important to me in the museum
when i feel that that is going in a way
that i don't like it i i i step in um
and my colleagues have heard me um do
that
the spirit of an institution needs to be
a nurturing one especially i think all
museums should university museums or
non-university museums
um
the
desire for collaboration and i was so
thrilled to hear the students yesterday
talk about that
and by collaboration um
is comes back to that generosity spirit
you know it for the museum to function
well it's a lot of different people with
a lot of different backgrounds have it
with different mandates
sometimes those mandates are completely
opposite if you just put it in kind of a
list of duties they sometimes are
polarizing
to
ultimately get to the end goal we have
to figure out how to work together and
there has to be a respect that you're
not always going to be right um there
has to be a respect that you're willing
to actually learn that someone else has
something of value to say
um and to me that's the essence of
collaboration
all of that for me
ultimately is leading to one goal and
this is something i feel i've always
instilled and
call it colleagues have worked with me
teams that have worked with me the
students i hope that are working and we
have a lot of students at the museum who
are working or volunteering in different
capacities
is understanding that each of us are
a small piece of getting to one larger
goal
for me it's not about me it's not about
the work i'm doing it's not about the
work you're doing it's about what we're
trying to impact
it's the impact on other people's lives
that matters first and understanding how
you fit into that
is essential
and whether it's you know kind of an
assistant in them in the marketing
department
understanding how what they're doing is
not just a task to get the job done
but the larger purpose of the
institution and every single level is
important to understand
and i think being able to have those
skill sets to bring that together
and the institution that allows you to
see that
and and feel it and make that difference
i think is important great
wonderful thank you so much for these
five wonderful responses now we've got a
we've got a good hour and 20 minutes
for you to just fire away from out there
so those mics are available and
please pepper this panel with as many
questions as you want to deliver having
had a few days to really load up
oh yeah yep
simone said and what i've observed here
which has been so inspiring
and if i had to take one word to
describe what i've seen here shock in
terms of you and your staff and what
you've created here it would be delight
there seems to be such a delight that
everyone here takes
laser focus on mission
but the delight that you take in seeing
your staff do their jobs the delight
that the staff takes in each other's
work is so inspiring and i think that if
it can be about that um there's a sense
of play that can lead to creativity all
of that but um but i re that that's been
so inspiring to me and i think um speaks
to real leadership so thank you for
modeling that so beautifully with you
and your staff and everyone here at yale
yeah i think i think it's palpable here
yeah
but it comes from the very team building
that simone just talked about no one you
know you get much too much credit as a
director i think we all feel that you
know i mean you sort of set the stage
you know and then if you've hired well
and put a great team together they do
the work
a lot of people don't realize that if
you give away power intelligently
in the best sense you gain a greater
power that your is what you're seeking
for your institution and its mission
and some people just don't get it and
something there's something energizing
about a kind of collective effort
i don't want to sound like an ex-soviet
or anything but it's
but but it's true it's kind of
empowering and uh you know it's
collaboration is embedded in it and you
can do very different things when you
work together it sounds like such a
simplistic thing to say but it in many
ways it's the hardest thing to achieve
yeah
okay thank you everyone and we're who
has a mic out there and ready to go i've
got the mic
okay uh good morning my name is jody
season wine i'm currently the melon
curatorial fellow for academic programs
at the princeton university art museum
and i want to thank you so much for
sharing all of your stories and for
everyone sharing their stories about
some of the wonderful things they've
been doing in their museums my question
is more towards when we run into some
barriers
i work a lot with faculty and students
in the galleries and i found students
are always willing i joke that i'm going
to throw them in the deep end and ask
students who are not art historians to
confront works of art and they always
rise to the challenge and they are happy
to take that risk maybe because they're
not in their classroom and being in the
galleries frees them to take that risk
but my question is more about um
encouraging faculty to take risks i've
had a number of ins
instances
where i've
asked a junior faculty member an
assistant professor a dynamic teacher to
think about doing a deeper collaboration
with a museum be it an exhibition
proposal or creating a new course around
the collection and
in two separate instances i can think of
the professor said to me come back after
i have tenure and then we can talk
and so my question really goes to
institutional barriers to risk taking
and these faculty feel that not only
would it
perhaps take away from their time
working on things that count towards
their tenure file but maybe
could even hurt their chances of getting
tenure because the institution
does not honor work in a museum as
something that's considered on par with
publishing their book or the kinds of
work that they need to do to get tenure
so i'm curious to hear from you if
you've encountered similar institutional
barriers to risk taking and what
suggestions you would have for those of
us in the museum to help transform our
institutions culture to really embrace
us as partners and value the work that
we do and that their faculty do thank
you
well i thought i think i'll take a crack
at that and then i'm sure there'll be
lots of others joining in for one thing
i think thank you for the question i
think it's a really really great
question and i think it also speaks to
the broader
way when which we talk a lot
about our unique capacity to take risks
right academic museums college and
university art museums because we don't
have a gate and because we're all about
learning and
i think we don't talk as often about the
barriers to that to actually fulfilling
that potential right and i think you're
right i would agree that that one of the
barriers or the barriers can be faculty
frankly
um
and so i guess what i would say i'd say
a couple things i think one is
like the best strategy that i've seen
and that we've had is by modeling it
and so finding partners faculty partners
who are just temperamentally
intellectually
more risk-taking
farther along in their careers have less
at stake whatever whatever that is right
and doing things with them and then
crowing about them so then publishing
publicizing it talking about it getting
up at the faculty meetings and stroking
them
all designed to give people permission
give them permission
to to follow that path so i think that's
that's like a really effective one and i
think the other one is really to
position the museum
as a place where students and faculty
can make mistakes
and and and take risks and to kind of
treat it as a kind of liminal space
where you can do that and so
really announce that that's what that's
what a museum can do
and let them
claim that so the point of what they're
doing is not that it's going to be a
tenurable project i mean i guess that
would be another strategy we could talk
about is how do you get museum work and
practice to have more you know to have
more credit within the academic system
that'd be one strategy but the other one
that i'm really speaking to is the way
in which you really say no like what you
can really do here which you probably
can't do within the curriculum as easily
is you can play and you can explore a
scholarship that otherwise might you
might not be able to do or you can
explore ways of teaching that you think
might not quite make it it can be a kind
of testing ground
so
those those are kind of my my two ideas
someone else want to take that well i
just say that um and i don't think this
is
particular to harvard but i think it's
in many ways especially prominent there
although it's changing now
harvard has historically had very much a
kind of alphanumeric bias
you know the notion that if it's not a
text if it's not a number it's somehow
suspect as a form of knowledge
and that's changing very dramatically
now at harvard but it's it's very much
been a part of our history and
we've been trying to make the argument
that
you know works of art are actually very
powerful teaching and learning resources
and
um oftentimes they're beautiful things
oftentimes they're not but in reality
they are the physical embodiment the
materialization of ideas values
traditions emotions attitudes
and when you begin to look at them from
that perspective especially within the
context of a university i think they can
be very powerful things
i'm assuming our campus is just like all
of your campuses especially in terms of
the debates now going on about the
nature of pedagogy
my very strong feeling is that at the
beginning of the 21st century when the
visual is so privileged art museums
within the context of a university have
enormous potential and it's just
i think a lot of the struggle is getting
people to recognize especially faculty
that works of art can be much more than
simply an illustration that's the thing
that drives us insane um you know works
of art they're potent they're powerful
they're active they have agency they're
a form of evidence and
one of the things we're trying to do is
get faculty to understand that you can
actually slow down and teach in
different ways with works of art so
we're we're very sensitive to sort of
trying to to pace the tempo of teaching
and learning with works of art
let me just add to this and tommy may
remember this since you are a melon
fellow at princeton tom and i were
invited to a con sort of convening of uh
by the melon foundation of ten of the
largest civic museums i think it was
maybe three years ago or oh god it's
more than that now but harvard neil was
invited to participate in that meeting
and at one point
uh they asked them where these other big
pacific museums where are you finding
your
young curators and where are they coming
from and i'll never forget that rusty
powell from the national gallery piped
up and said you know i look every year
at all the cvs from casva the art
historians who come to us and frankly we
never seem to hire any of them because
they've never worked in teams with other
people they've been so narrowly trained
that they don't have this experience of
the kind of collaboration and
willingness to take a certain kind of
risk on these trajectories to get a
degree where you tunnel in for you know
a particular kind of knowledge not that
that's bad but it doesn't seem to be the
model that's producing this the young
people at best thrive in our
institutions and i don't know if anyone
wants to follow up on that or whether
that's helpful to you as a response
well um i i just wanted to offer some
strategies that we found fairly helpful
at colby and that has been to partner
with other
organizations on campus so for instance
that we have a new melon funded center
for arts and humanities
in which we're running we're
co-organizing labs in the museum out of
that so faculty can apply to the center
receive faculty development grants and
run their classes their labs in the
museum we also have strong partnerships
with the center for civic engagement and
so somehow by forming those partnerships
and collaboration faculty are given a
kind of legitimacy or
the work that they're doing is
supported by another
part of the campus
organization and i think that's been
highly successful i also just want to
point to the work that i've found to be
a really great model for this which is
the work ian berry is doing at the tang
when you begin to think about your
faculty as
partners in intellectual production and
so going to them early on and working
from their expertise
again it's probably hard to engage free
pre-tenure faculty in that but like tina
says you can model it from the more
senior faculty down and i think
really thinking about that pool of
faculty as resources for the
intellectual production that we do in
museums is is a great model
adam from a large public research
university's perspective um the campus
at ut we have 50 000 students on campus
and
a lot of colleges
and there isn't such a thing as a kind
of faculty club it's it's hard to find
your way around a campus like that
one of the areas that i very much wanted
to strengthen was our impact on on
campus and one of the first things i did
was actually meet with many of you
to get your ideas and see what was
happening
but another thing i think that was
pointed out is is
especially in a large campus kind of
finding that finding a hook or a center
and then building from there
and in a sense i feel like we're
continuing to do that and one of the
hooks that for ut was just remarkable
that it exists one of the reasons i love
working there is a new program was
created a few years ago called signature
courses at the university um there are
undergraduate courses freshman courses
which
every student is required to take
distinguished faculty that are training
students in a very kind of unique
cross-disciplinary way to
get give them the college level skills
in
research and writing and discussing and
speaking and it's cross-disciplinary
it's out of the classroom often and so
we realized they're doing exactly what
we're wanting to do
we now have 2000 students coming through
the museum with faculty through that
program alone and twenty thousand
students total coming through the museum
um but modeling kind of picking them as
partners and then being able to say
you know look what they're doing um
modeling it from there kind of you know
get a few wins in your pocket and build
from that
on a similar level we now are kind of
trying to target different departments
this last year we just hosted the math
department's faculty annual every
faculty on campus has their little
gathering we let them have their party
at the museum just so we can get them in
the doors and see them you can't do
everyone so we kind of go through
departments um in different in different
ways so in some way it's almost like
cultivating relationships and and
opening the doors and letting them see
how you can have an impact
i would just add briefly the um
my advice would be to play the long game
and
if you have pretend your faculty
they
their responsibility really is to focus
on their research and get tenure
but that doesn't mean that you can't
build relationships with them
and show an interest in their research
go to their lectures rather than just
expecting them to always come to the
museum
so that when the faculty member has
tenure and is ready to really engage
with you on a project
you are um you've primed them to really
experience the museum
in a different way
and i think that that um approach
um is difficult because you know the
short-term gains are so easy you know
you you i can think of a new faculty
member at dartmouth
who is especially interested in um
images of war
and we have a fabulous collection to
teach with that
and she's dying to do an exhibition
but she's got to get tenure first and i
think that you ha you have to kind of
just think about the long-term benefits
and actually jim from the ashmolean did
a great job of talking about that i mean
sometimes it's a cup of coffee
and just showing that the museum is open
and available
and the barriers that exist that's
that's just you know you have to find a
way uh to solve that because ultimately
i don't think there's anyone uh who
teaches on on college and university
campuses that can't work with museums i
i think we have something for everyone
how about another question
here we go
here you go
hello
i'm lucy oakley from the gray art
gallery at nyu and i wanted to let you
know that a couple of years ago with
helen evans the great curator of
byzantine art at the metropolitan museum
and i
co-authored for the college art
association
new guidelines for tenure that included
a strong recommendation for university
departments to include museum
publications that have a scholarly bent
in their tenure decisions so any junior
faculty who are expressing concern about
tenure issues
might be told that these new guidelines
are encouraging their departments to
include any uh publication that they do
with your museum in their tenure uh
assessment all right thank you very much
thank you for that very good everyone
bear that in mind you know can i say one
other thing the other thing i'd add to
that last question is we
we want to serve everyone on campus but
at the same time we also
want to be thoughtful about who our
partners are
the thing that scares me sometimes is
that
university art museums can simply be
seen as seen as a kind of service center
on campus where we simply fetch things
for faculty
we want our faculty to understand that
museum curators and educators can help
guide them through collections
and see things that they normally
wouldn't see from their own perspective
so um
as i said we look carefully for the
right partners you were somebody was
just talking about working with a
faculty member on an exhibition that's
going to be a big part of our future but
we also want good faith partners
we have lots of conversations with
faculty members who have you know it's
like any college campus there's no
shortage of good ideas even brilliant
ideas but
when we hear things like um and by the
way i'll be on sabbatical next year and
i won't be answering my email um
that that strikes us as not a good faith
partner for us in terms of putting
together an exhibition or a research
initiative so
i just wanted to throw that out as a
kind of cautionary tale yeah
thanks tom
go ahead hi there my name is alexa
miller and i actually have one more
comment in response to that question
because it's such an important one i
encounter that issue all the time as an
independent consultant who works at a
lot of sites in higher education and i
wanted to give a shout out to megan
voiler who's i think is in this room
megan are you here she's uh there she's
over there she's at university of south
florida in tampa at the contemporary
arts
museum and they face that issue
she's working on an incredible project
with
between the museum and all of the
schools of health nursing medicine
pharmacology social work um on a new
program and megan did something
extremely innovative in response to that
challenge which was she
enlisted
the help of
an organizational psychologist who is
working very hard to get tenure
to actually be the prime researcher on
the impact of this program and let me
tell you that person is extremely
energized and motivated around getting
the right data out of this project
because she intends to use it for as
part as part of her research for her
tenure case and it's just a brilliant
example of a really a win-win situation
because as museums we have to partner
with with social scientists as my
colleague dabney haley talked about
yesterday to show our impact and that
that's a resource that's right there so
i just wanted to mention that
although you know on a more positive
note um
i think about this all the time
as university art museums we can call on
intellectual and research resources
that very few museums in the world can
we have special relationships with
faculty we have bright hard-working
ambitious students so
we're actually in a very very good
position
yeah
who's up next someone have a mic out
there hi
um i'm ruth slavin i'm from the
university of michigan
and having had the benefit of being
there for a long time i have many many
relationships with many different
faculty and diverse disciplines and i
wanted to
speak up to the
related issue of how museum culture
could assist university culture and
specifically in the humanities these are
not my ideas they reflect conversations
with faculty colleagues
first the create the recognition full
recognition of the creation of art as a
formal as research and as discovery for
our our art school colleagues and to
support them in that
second
enhancing the culture of collaboration
and academic humanities many young
faculty don't also don't get credit or
full or they won't be tenured if their
first book or their second book is a
collaborative project
the creative and collaborative nature of
museum work could be a model within the
university and i think people in
positions of power and leadership at
university museums could enhance
that direction in the humanities
specifically
next joint appointments
of
key faculty with museums so that their
museum work would be fully recognizable
for tenure and that it would be part of
the negotiation of their hiring
contract
and so those are some ideas that have
been battered around at michigan it's a
great idea
thank you very much i think i'll i'll
take a crack at that partly because
dartmouth hired
michigan's provost to be our new
president
so a lot a lot of these ideas are coming
to dartmouth and um
i mean i think that one of the
key debates happening on our campus
right now is around experiential
learning
and the idea that
despite this conference teaching now is
an active engaged
encounter with
the professor and the students on the
same level
pretty much like
we were doing with the gallery talks
and we're learning together
and um it involves an element of failure
and also an element of risk and an
element of reflection
and this kind of learning by doing
is transforming
higher education
and i think as higher education
is transformed
we have to lose the old models this idea
that a collaborative project
could not be counted as tenure it just
seems from a different century you know
and and i hope that you know um as
museums transform themselves i i think
we're gonna play an increasingly
important role
because when we um
hear the challenges that you just laid
out you know it sounds very familiar to
us but familiar to us from from the past
not from where we're headed so i think
we have a bright future in that regard
because i think that the kind of
collaborative interdisciplinary
teaching that we're doing on a daily
basis is the future of higher education
at least as far as we can can see it in
the near future
and i just think that what it means is
we've got to work with our provost work
with our president work with our deans
to educate them and and you know it's
difficult because they leave you know
as i've experienced
so so i always thought i was coming to
dartmouth to educate the students i
didn't realize that actually probably my
biggest role is educating the provost
and president and deans to really
understand why we're critically
important so i hope that helps a little
bit
that's an important point michael
yeah and i think that also that that
that brings up for me another thread
that's really important for us to talk
about and that is
the incredible ways in which museums are
really well positioned to help higher
education as it evolves and all the
threats and opportunities facing it
and the the places in which it isn't and
really talking up really talking about
that very very frankly as a group i
think would be really useful a lot of a
lot of that's come up i think
you know a lot of what we've been saying
this morning and have come up in the
questions are things about the museum's
ability to be a place where you can
learn experientially the museum's
capacity for risk-taking the museum's
nimbleness in contrast to the rigidity
of a lot of the academy
right like those are all things that are
incredible pluses and that higher ed is
gonna
you know can look to us
as as as like safety valves for right
like ways in which it can maneuver
better
but there's also
there's also real risks i mean i think
that you know i think a lot of and maybe
the audience can speak to this but at a
lot of universities and colleges when
push comes to shove in terms of dollars
it's going to be the units that are
making that are bringing in income and
that are that are academic units that
that are gonna that are gonna hold and
they'll be looking to cut areas with
that that you know that don't produce
revenue frankly right maybe not at all
of our our colleges and universities but
certainly it's some
and so i think that makes that makes me
think a lot about
the extent to which museums and we've
we've we've touched on this too
are at least have a foot in um
you know in in in a role as an academic
unit the extent to which museum staff
our faculty or have part of their
positions our faculty the extent to
which we can actually have courses or
run courses is all really really really
important when we think about our own
future and i think those are connected
issues because
you know in in an economic downturn we
soon learn
who's
mission critical and who's nice to have
you know and uh right that's right so so
if we we have to really keep
uh
making it clear that we are mission
critical and and i think that's a a lot
of what we're doing here
is learning from each other about how to
to make that case even clearer and
louder and and more powerfully but i do
i do think that that's something that i
think about a lot is the um
in a way
you know and it goes back to what you
were saying you know i art is an
illustration
and
uh we're not
in the business of decorating offices
you know and there are there are so many
sort of mission drift moments where you
know you've just got to always pull it
back to teach them with objects
but going back to them the main question
i mean i think this
uh one of the roles we play is is
teaching about creativity and innovation
and those have impacts beyond your
constituency departments of art history
and studio art and classics and
anthropology that gets all over the
campus and and you know these are
critical
things being taught right now and if we
are embedded in that and part of that
moment we're going to be mission
critical
there's two two points i wanted to make
to um
that
question one is there i do think the
museum can play um a role of especially
on again a large campus
of bringing different um thinkers
together we're going through the process
of reinstalling our collection which
is planned to happen in 2017 and then
we're going to invite you all there to
hopefully host this conference then
at that time
we've done a series of conversations and
this has happened in other realms but
i'll just talk about it in this
particular one where we've invited
faculty from across campus to sit with
our curators and educators to think
about
kind of what we should look like in the
future and you know one of these talks
could be a neuroscientist chair of the
architecture department an art historian
um
dif people from different areas of
campus and there's a topic that might be
kind of the object in space you know
or how do we use technology in the
galleries what are the um issues
and i can't tell you how many times i've
heard of those
conversations where they say gosh i've
been meaning to talk to you for this
particular reason or that wanting to
reach out to each other and thanking us
for actually being a hub to bring them
together to think and talk
and also thanking us for being a hub for
their own intellectual
stimulation which is another point to
that the how to bring faculty in
um being a place for their you know
we especially at the blanton play a
major role in austin as a kind of a
cultural um
and a museum for the community and that
includes the faculty as well
um
another part that i think is important
um and anytime those things happen i
share it with the provost and the
president immediately about that kind of
collaborative spirit which i do think is
a model for for other work on campus
to the point of financial strains um
major public research universities
especially
um and the university of texas has
battled um a question of
kind of the what what an education
should look like the role humanities
plays in an education the role of kind
of intellectual pursuit and the ability
for students to really think broadly
beyond their kind of degree that they're
getting to get a job
and i think the art museum
it's important um
we play a really important role about
the message
of what we value on this campus what
kind of the intellectual pursuit should
be and that broad curiosity it says a
lot about what the university of texas
goals are its missions what they believe
our citizens should look like and i
think that's an incredibly important
large picture message for our citizens
for me the students on that campus i
hope they all go into that museum if
nothing else to become well-rounded
citizens
and
our patrons and our visitors of tomorrow
and i think the message
that it sends for a university that that
is part of our core value is important
especially in public research
universities that are battling this
regularly
that's i think that's really interesting
i think all of our universities and
colleges are interested in training not
only
you know wonderfully bright people to
have this great liberal arts education
or scientific education but also
whatever it is to go out in the world
and hopefully become leaders of some
kind in their communities where they
choose to live they don't all graduate
from yale and stay here in new haven
needless to say
so
how they do that you know is i think
really
something the administration actually
pays a great deal attention to and our
role in helping those people become
you know potential leaders of the future
is i think really important and becoming
more evident that work we're doing i
have no doubt at all that our current
and recent gallery wordle teachers and
undergraduate gallery guides amongst
those are going to be some of our
greatest benefactors
uh not just in terms of how they go out
into the world but they're going to come
back they have had experiences here that
matter so much to them
that you know they're going to they're
going to be vying to be on our governing
boards our trustees in the future
there's no question of it
i would also just add the um
the model of group curating that we saw
so beautifully exemplified
yesterday afternoon in kate's group's
presentation is one that i'm
increasingly convinced of is the way is
the model of the future and one that we
can really lead in
and i think the way in which we can lead
in it is that we have a larger group as
um as michael and tom were just saying
from which to pool and if we begin to
think about including faculty and
students in i mean we at colby have
begun to work as um as a team as a
curatorial team making decisions about
permanent installation permanent
collection installation this is
something that we're all doing obviously
but what would happen if we brought a
faculty member or two or three in which
to really model this is what this looks
like you know when you when you talk
about it abstractly that's one thing but
when you bring them into the you know
hundreds of meetings that go into the
decisions that make i think you could
really expand
uh their understanding of that as a
model and i think they would also really
impact the decisions that you're making
in terms of your presentation of the
collection so i'm excited about thinking
about that students as well i think
there's a way to include their voices so
instead of um
i guess what i'm saying is kind of
merging those teams together in a way
that i think could be really interesting
and productive yeah great next questions
yeah sarah so i'm sara lynn ricardi from
the spencer museum of art at the
university of kansas and i want to
mention
uh something that has to do with the
long haul
and the long haul um
in a really exciting way because when i
got to the university eight years ago
um i had not been on the job
three weeks before i got a call from a
colleague who was the director of the
biodiversity institute
and he said
we
victor bailey the director of the hall
center and i have bonded together and
we'd like you to join our team
and what we what they had the vision for
at that point was something called the
commons at ku
and now that partnership is nine years
old it's all three of us we have a space
on campus
we give away research grants seed grants
we have programs we are hybrid in that
nature in other words it's not just the
art museum always modeling always being
the initiator but in some ways how do
you get invited to the party
and the party is not always the party on
your terms
so what i would like to suggest to all
of us is yes
we need to model we need to prototype we
need to invite we need to initiate we
but we also need to be the kind of
partners that others wish to invite
and that has given us incredible
uh currency at the provost's office
and when they say the commons we we are
very i love your word crow
we're crowing about it all the time
whoever whoever used crow
um
because when we say the commons we say
and the commons is a partnership of the
spencer museum of art the biodiversity
institute and the hall center for
humanities and we all get bigger so that
has just been incredibly important
and so so to just leave you with this
this has not threatened the uh identity
of the university art museum and our
role with objects but has actually
expanded us into a more hybrid
personality where other entities begin
to see how we can adapt to some of their
agenda
thank you very much sarah
somebody over there who's got a mic now
i i think i'm lucky enough to be holding
the mic um and anne goodyear from the
bowdoin college museum of art um and
thank you so much for your comments
they're very illuminating um obviously
one of the very special things that
museums do is to provide a place for
students to encounter real objects which
is not a typical uh thing for people to
do necessarily in our virtual world
but um speaking of uh digitization and
and
what's possible nowadays in terms of the
digital humanities i wondered if you
might each be able to expand a little
bit on how you are developing digital
resources on perhaps to stimulate
collaboration and perhaps even new
publishing opportunities as you reach
out to partners across campus and i know
that each of you has given thought to
that but i'd love to hear more about the
strategies you're adopting in that area
go ahead who wants that
what's at first i can take that i mean i
think that that's a critical
question and um
at the hood uh you know we are have an
ongoing project to digitize our
collection
and
uh we're not only thinking of a
searchable database which is extremely
useful but
we're working actively and kathy hart
who's here today is leading this charge
in
building a web portal
so that our faculty
and students will have a
an access to
the objects in a way that they've never
had before
for example tracking works that are used
for teaching so that you can find a
faculty member who taught with that
object in a class last term
might help a faculty member teach that
object this term
and so that sort of
idea is to sort of push the collection
out on the campus so
i think that's the priority for now um
we've worked with the newcomb center at
dartmouth on an app for the
orosco mural which was just given by the
obama administration a national historic
landmark status
and so this this app was was a great
collaboration
but
i mean my remarks earlier were
more about the bigger challenge which
which i think can cannot be um solved by
one institution alone i think as a field
we have to think about what it means
to be a teaching museum in the digital
age
and there's huge opportunities and um i
think that we can solve these together
great and um
um i also think this really comes to the
question jacques that you asked about
collection sharing and i think there's a
way we can think more innovatively about
this and and i know this is something
that you and i have spoken about about
such
institutions in such close proximity but
and i think this goes back to james
shulman's question yesterday too about
how are digital collections impacting
and influencing our work today and i
think it comes down to
access but also thinking more broadly
about our collections and thinking about
academic museums with all of the
resources we have the diverse
intellectual resources and the diverse
collections more broadly and if we can
use libraries as a model here i think
we've taken a giant step in thinking
about i mean it's not really
interlibrary loan
it's not that model but there is a way
in which i think we can release the kind
of fetishization of the object a little
bit
and think about how can we be informed
by and educated by the collections at
yale williams dartmouth harvard ut
austin the blanton in all of us in this
audience in more productive ways and i
think that opens up in many ways it
opens up the world of art to all of our
institutions and i think quite exciting
ways so i'm not sure quite yet what that
looks like but i feel like that's the
future
yeah i would i mean anna you and i have
talked about this too but i guess i
would i would follow up on on sharon and
michael's
remarks in two ways um
i think obviously we all need to
digitize and catalog our collections and
we all know that um
i think the idea of interfaces that
actually
allow for student and faculty browsing
and that publish
all of the data that we've got around
the usage of objects by faculty
is an obvious idea and we should pursue
it and it's sort of actually something
that we you know that that museum
educate all the museum educators in the
room especially those who've worked on
k-12 resources know that like they
invented this idea which is like why
would you reinvent
the wheel and how organic chemistry is
using objects if they've done it over
there like why are we all doing that on
our own right why couldn't we in fact
collectively solve some of those bigger
problems
but the other thing i think
is that it's really really hard for
small institutions to invest in
platforms for online publication for
example that's the thing that big
museums are doing with big funding from
the melon and the getty um
so there's uh there's a there's a
there's a really important way in which
we should be thinking together about how
to co-develop some of those platforms
and i think those are platforms for
publication you know i think it would be
incredible if we had better more nimble
more robust platforms for student and
faculty publication that were digital
because we can't all produce
sixty thousand dollar print publications
and we know that that that we need to
invent we need to invest in those
and i think things like
you know things like sharing
you know sharing resources sharing the
ways in which we are working with
faculty and faculty are working with
objects and doing that collaboratively
is
is another way and then finally i'd say
beyond collection sharing it's really
you know there's ways in which college
and university art museums haven't
caught up with broader museums in terms
of really thinking about
online learning as a creative
collaborative platform not just a you
know not just a teaching one and so
really investing in the ways that
students can
play and collaborate and tag and
do all kinds of giving back to us around
objects but around other things i think
is something
we'll all be looking at too
i'll add just to it there um the blant
and one of our top kind of my top next
priorities is to actually
strengthen
the technology and including a lot of
what was talked about in terms of the
collection as a resource for
um teaching and being able to access and
understand what we have but
um there's another layer and again each
institution is very unique and the
blanton you know we sit on this campus
teaching is core to our mission
important to me
um but we also happen to sit in what is
now the 11th largest city in the country
and the fastest growing city in the
country um and we are the only art
museum in town so we play a very public
role
we're actually set up to serve both as a
gateway to the community as well as
impact on campus
and
i say that to just give you a sense that
the museum
does have a
somewhat robust
exhibition program and programs for
audiences generally um
and again core in education and teaching
our exhibition programs i think are
important
they say something about the research we
are adding to the field at large as a
public research university might do
um and by that i mean within art history
and one of the things that i'm really
curious about is the fact that we're
sitting on this campus and in a city
that is vibrant with technology the kind
of next
kind of
center of technology and what can we
learn from that and impacting in that
process of developing um your curatorial
practice or educational practice
one of the things that i've especially
loved is
the fact that we have students on the
campus
and they can inform and let us help us
understand how they think
even the conversation yesterday about
using a flickr account
we hired and just hired a current
student who was while she was finishing
her studies hired her as a part-time
person to help us navigate social media
that is the form of communication for
students if we're going to want students
to come in on their own not necessarily
through faculty courses we have to be
able to communicate in that way what
better way than have a student who
understands that so much better than we
do do it and she's basically in charge
of it
she also happens to have created a
tumblr account called cave to canvas
that is
has more followers than most public
museums do
there's brilliant things that are
happening out there
and i think being able to communicate in
the way students communicate
is really important and technology is
front and center
and one of the things i think that we're
not doing right at museums broadly is
technology is thought of as at the end
we develop our programs we develop our
exhibitions and then we think let's put
some now let's make it to you know let's
put it in technology
technology to me looks like
today we talk about it the way the
typewriter outside of the office
used to be talked about you know we'll
send it out and they'll kind of type it
up
it it's that's the way we look at it we
have a technology department and it sits
out there you know we'll send it to them
they'll type it up and go somewhere
um but it's not going to be like that it
is it is every
part of our being in the future and we
need to understand it yeah i'd like to
address that question more in the
context of how we're also collecting art
made
in the digital age because it's very
clear to me just thinking back to my own
youth as an artist that museums were
very
slow to pick up on a lot of the really
important art being made in the 60s and
70s when many of us got going starting
these alternative spaces and
in cities like san francisco chicago la
new york and elsewhere now that real
estate and the cost of living in a lot
of these centers have changed because
very expensive and alternative forms of
production are moving into you know
youtube and all kinds of forms
not only because the technology is there
because of the economics they're facing
younger artists i think we need to be
much more open as to what's being
created
and what is it we're going to collect
and start to place our bets on and
adding it to the collection we're here
for example
we've had prince drawings and
photography together as a department and
we're going to be splitting that up so
that prints and drawings will stay
together and we'll be found in the
department of photography and digital
media and what does that mean what
should we be purchasing well we've been
we've had some sort of fairly sure bets
you know john walsh gave us a wonderful
bill viola piece that you know he worked
on john's you know retrospective we just
bought the great kentridge three monitor
piece and anamorphic line so you know
certain things you can sort of say well
these are you know they're they're going
to be here for the ages and stand up
but what are young people making that's
a real consequence how are they sharing
their their production and and how are
they sharing even in some cases i know
some of our photo students are doing
exhibitions of photography digitally
online they put them up back and forth
adding to them over a two-month period
and take them off and we're used to
going into galleries where you
physically see this stuff they're doing
it differently
so i think this is another place where
we need to also invite
younger people into the sharing of what
they're making much as you saw
the student curators last night teach us
something we don't know all of this we
have things to learn particularly those
of us who are a little older
let me just expand on that a little bit
tom shapiro asked a really provocative
question last night at dinner he said do
contemporary artists need museums
and i kind of um knee-jerkly said of
course they do but as you're saying i
mean i think we're living in a different
world where there is production
happening outside of the museum and
asking what our role is going to be and
mediating that interpreting that
presenting that is really an important
question and um it's one that i think is
um more complex than at least i've
allowed it to be in my thinking
that almost takes me back to the the
yale center for british art the curator
talking about
the visitor who said will it be a
welcoming experience for me and and you
know i think that
we will be a relevant
institution to contemporary artists as
long as we're open and
not trying to define positions but but
sort of allowing ourselves to be nimble
and flexible and changing um constantly
as art changes and i think one of the
the
things that i always sort of
think about is that innovation happens
at the periphery
and you know a lot of um college
university art museums are running on
shoestring budgets and and performing
miracles under very difficult
circumstances but
you know it's those places that i think
are going to be the ones who are going
to
allow artists to direct the the focus of
the collection
and if we if we aren't uh you know we
have to avoid that that mistake of the
past and i know exactly what you mean
about the the the sort of
uh missing the 60s and 70s i mean
growing up in england it was amazing
that um even as as late as as sort of
the late 1970s the tate was still
debating whether picasso should be in
the collection i mean it's unbelievable
who's that
okay
no i just have to i have to add to that
because it's so interesting it brings up
so many things that are the thread
throughout the morning
um i think there's so much and with in
which so many ways in which
the production of art now and technology
and it's and the and the broader culture
and reception of art
are really going to push hard at museums
and
you know
i think they're going to push at our
assumption a lot of assumptions that
we've been making for the last few days
right an assumption about
all art happening are our walls and the
spaces where that that we exist in
working for a lot of art right what does
it mean if you're making work of art
that's a meal what does that mean to
your registrar if that work of art is a
meal that's getting that's going to be
ha that's going to happen in the museum
or outside the museum i think it's going
to push at a lot of our understandings
or notions of what a curator is and what
an educator is absolutely i mean my
daughter the other day my 11 year old
daughter i was looking at facebook and
she was like why are you looking at
facebook that's dead that's gone
and then she said here look at vines you
guys know what vines you know what vines
right six second videos six second
videos so we spent the last two and a
half days talking about close
observation and long looking and we're
doing it
for digital natives who are thinking in
six second increments and who are
spending seven hours a day on on digital
devices that's what it's come to now npr
you probably heard that story two days
ago but if you think about it
historically i mean imagine being an
illuminated manuscript
artist
in a monastery and then
gutenberg who's hanging out not in the
monastery but with the winemakers
notices the wine press and and invents
the printing press well that that shift
in technology was probably extremely
scary and we all deal as directors with
change management it's one of the
hardest things we deal with and i think
that
you know we have to have faith in
artists
that shift in technology produced dura
you know there's no questions about
faith and technology but we have to be
responsive we have to be
and so so i think i think what we've got
to we've got to embrace is that in a
constantly changing landscape we are
able to constantly change and i'm not
saying this is easy at all i think it is
a major thing for our field yeah great
the the only quick thing i'd add to that
is that
we like a lot of museums now have
actually assembled an internal group
made up primarily of our
conservators conservation scientists and
curatorial staff and i'm looking at
jessica martinez who's head of academic
and public programs i don't think dapp
is part of that group
anyway
it's a group that's come together to
talk about the issues and problems
presented by
time-based media new media
and it's a little frightening when you
see the issues and problems that are
headed our way and i just brought this
up because um after we had a big meeting
about it our modern and contemporary
curator pulled me aside and she said you
know i'm thinking about this it's got
lots of problems we're not really set up
for it are you
are you going to back me if we if
if we decide to move forward with this
acquisition and
i sort of surprised myself by
instinctively intuitively saying yes
without knowing what that really meant
in terms of you know financial
commitments but
to to just echo what tina was saying if
if we can't adapt and if we can't get
ready for
new works of art yeah we're going to be
left behind we're simply going to be and
i'm a picture person but we're simply
going to be museums with pictures and
frames on the wall and that's not the
future
but think about how much we've changed
already
and and just this conference i think is
part of that if you held this conference
20 years ago i think the discussions
would be very different
i always say this that i think a lot of
teaching museums 20 years ago were sort
of mini mets and they they thought that
they had a different
mission they they were sort of
community town and gown museums they
they were thinking very differently
and and i i really applaud this shift
and that gives me the hope that we can
adapt to change and um
let artists show the way you know that's
yeah absolutely and just as a reminder
remember it wasn't until
just recently that teaching museum was
not a pejorative term
the implication in the past used to be
it's a teaching museum
meaning the collections aren't very good
they deal with secondary material and
you know now we have to say like john
does a great teaching museum
well you know the other thing in this
field that i thought about a lot when i
was at the addison was how much the
great works were always borrowed from
our smaller institutions for the major
museums and there was nothing wrong with
that but frankly so little ever came
back the other way
and i remember when i did a
retrospective of george tooker at
andover having led 36 major paintings to
the met that they first refused the loan
and i thought well good god you know
after all of this what is that all about
right
and
you know it was we eventually did get
the law and i won't go into how but
but but but
you know it was it was at that point
when i also looked at a number of our
institutions where i saw people were
sort of yearning to always oh if just
once in my life i could have a show that
would go to one of these places this
would be the crowning thing for someone
working at university of college i
thought god what a pathetic sense of
ambition
can't we
can't we have something more interesting
if we were to do more of what we're
doing together which is to combine this
wonderful teaching mission the fact that
we're training the kind of people that
are only going to end up at these big
civic museums which frankly now are not
the most interesting places to work and
they're beset with huge financial
problems the monetization of their
collections you know boards of trustees
they're driving them all nuts i mean i
wouldn't touch i wouldn't touch a lot of
those places i don't know what you're
talking about
how about another question
could i actually say one thing
you you talked about excuse me you
talked about how
other institutions like to borrow just
the cream of what you have and that's a
huge challenge for us we have a big
collection and we're actually thinking
hard about strategies not simply with
other museums but with our faculty to
get them to not simply skim a truck top
across the top of our collections we
want them to go deeper because
presumably we found a good meaningful
reason to bring those things into our
collections and if they're not used they
probably shouldn't be there yeah but
this goes back to libraries when i came
to yale in 98 they had just begun to
transfer the entire collection off of
three by five typewritten cards onto a
database so in the older days if you
couldn't literally find the curator of
that collection or in the case sometimes
at the registrar and yale was keeping
double sets of books sort of like
truckers who want to get through
you know
you know how are you going to even find
out what was there much less gain access
to it which has other implications for
how we've needed to staff up to support
a more expanded use of making
collections you know accessible and that
i think something that you know we
haven't talked that much about but a
huge portion is not just building
facilities but creating enough resources
that you have more art handlers more
registrars more educators and people who
can deliver these things otherwise it's
just a false promise
question from the back if we may uh this
is max marmor from the samuel crest
foundation
i want to start with a story from the
pre-jock era at yale jock you came here
in 98
in 95 i had one of the most intriguing
professional experiences of my life at
yale i was on the yale re-accreditation
team
and was
on behalf of the libraries and i was
astonished as everyone was to discover
that a university like yale can be
reaccredited do it self-study be
assessed by an external visiting
committee with no mention being made of
the museums whatsoever
the simple reason for that and it's it's
unalterable is that accreditation is all
about apple to apple comparisons and
most schools don't have museums and so
museums do not figure in nationwide
re-accreditation processes uh brandeis
was reaccredited i think a couple of
years before it contemplating selling
its museum there is no mention of the
museum in the re-accreditation
self-study i've done a little bit of a
study of self-studies museums are almost
never mentioned because they're not
asked to be mentioned
um and so
what i learned from the yale experience
was thank heavens the the library
director said this is absurd let's
invoke the the museums as our partners
in collecting stewarding conserving and
mediating use of collections and you
know the continuity between the beinecke
library and the museums is pretty
self-evident
um so i'm on a bit of a campaign to
encourage museum directors at
universities and colleges around the
country
first of all to find out when their
school is going to be reaccredited
because they might not be consulted at
all about it they have their own
internal accreditation processes like
schools of architecture
graphic design and others but find out
have lunch with your library director
and make sure they do at least mention
the museums as pertinent to the
university or college reaccreditation
process i'd also love to know if i could
ask a show of hands how many folks in
the room know when their school is next
up for reaccreditation
all right it's about a third of the room
um i think there's a problem and i'd
love to hear what the director the fifth
of the room
okay fifth of the room
we're charitable in new england
i'd love to know what you all make of
this kind of situation i'm not
suggesting by the way the museum should
be part of the reaccreditation process i
think it's impossible simply because
most colleges and universities don't
have them and the accreditation agencies
can't set up those kinds of standards
that don't apply across the board but
short of that and sort of the headache
of reaccreditation what can museum
directors and their staffs do to at
least be surfaced in the process
i think that's really right max and
that's a real risk and um i think it
goes back to what michael said a moment
ago it's not just about educating the
faculty and students about our relevance
on campus it's really the administration
and to make sure you're at the table at
that high level
of decision making and planning and
reaccrediting is so critical or else
you've become irrelevant
or you at least your role on campus is
not acknowledged at that high level and
i think
i mean jacques just seeing you and
yale's new president on the stage here i
mean it's those kinds of relationships
that keep us alive in institutions like
this so if you don't have them you're
sunk
sorry
well thank you my name is amanda cross i
work for bright spot strategy we're a
consulting firm and actually in addition
to working with ruth on the university
of michigan's museum of arts
strategic plan
we had the pleasure of working with
the university of california's santa
cruz new institute of arts and sciences
with john weber and i wanted to try and
touch on the conversation of engaged
learning and in attracting faculty and
so
if you don't know the muse the institute
is not a museum
it's very much trying to be an intercept
of a museum and
a place for students and faculty to
collaborate over interdisciplinary
studies
and in coming up with its vision and its
plan for the facility
we brought together faculty across the
institution
and the what came across and the
conversation we had and what i really am
interested in hearing from you is the
intercept between making and viewing
and what
needs to happen in the building and else
elsewhere on campus and online to
attract faculty and students away from
the other places that they have to
create things together and exhibit
things together and whether those things
can happen in the same place or they can
happen in isolated places tom you
mentioned a number of labs and
dedicated places in the harvard
facilities so whether in the future you
see those things really intercepting
fully or
what role they have in the art museum
let me take that one because i'm an
alumnus if you see santa cruz and
actually on the dean's arts council that
that's generated this project and
sorry ian but we stole john away to
help run that so you're now doing a
great job
yeah
but you know
as a graduate you know of uc santa cruz
i was in the very first class there one
of the things that was most important to
i think a lot of us who went there with
the incredibly close relationships we
had with faculty at the time first of
all it was about an eight to one ratio
in 1965 through 69
beyond that was pass fail you got
written evaluations from your faculty
and early on there were some major
experiments done with undergraduate art
education with a huge grant from the
carnegie grant carnegie foundation my
senior year that allowed people from the
arts science humanities
to come to campus and experiment
together and myself and 15 other young
students were didn't know why but we
were asked to be a part of an
interdisciplinary experimental art
workshop led by robert watts the fluxus
artist and during that year we first
were visited by merce cunningham and
john cage who did an amazing performance
and spent a few days with us talking
about chants and improvisation and
walked off on mushroom hunts in the
woods with change and and you know we
saw george siegel
alan capro
uh you know
and uh james lee byers dan flavin it
just the whole year was unbelievable it
sort of blew every assumption you could
have had about contemporary art but it
was that kind of experimentation with
people across disciplines
uh that shook up i think for a lot of us
the notion of what one might do if one
were entering the arts that was a little
less than just traditional but more
multidisciplinary so you know one of the
things i've actually encouraged as alum
also of uc davis is that you know we
were talking and others have mentioned
library interlibrary loans well you know
it's required by state statute that that
all you see
trend campuses share their books with
each other a lot of people don't know
it's required by statute that they also
share their art but they've never
ever really created a
major network to do that now santa cruz
is building its institution which is so
far behind in collecting one kind of
work they're going to concentrate more
on the digital and the new davis is
building a new uh museum and rachel
teagle and john weber applying to melon
for a planning grant to think about how
the uc system might do what some of us
have done and it's one of my real hopes
out of this kind of conferences we're
having is that other parts of the
country public or private college
universities will think of other models
of what they might do together and that
not all of them have to try to do the
same thing
so santa cruz has this wonderful
interdisciplinary thing that's gone on
where the sciences and marine biology
and all these other things physics have
been strengthened and they now i think
have realized that they need to
strengthen the arts and humanities and
integrate them
so i'm delighted to know you're part of
that wonderful process but it is a model
everyone might want to look at when you
think of what does one need to do as an
institution which might
not need to be done if you complement in
collaboration with other potential
partners
um i think what i might add to that is
that
in
my view there are very few universities
in this country that have had the kind
of
generous embrace of the visual arts like
yale
harvard has been quite different in fact
our current president drew faust who was
working hard to change this and said
something a couple of years ago that i'd
never thought about but she said harvard
is good at collecting art they're good
at studying art but they're not very
good at making art
and a perfect example of that is the
carpenter's center which is right next
door to the harvard art museums it's
corbusier's only building in north
america and that's really where the
practice of art takes place at harvard
and
historically there has been very little
interaction between two very close
physical neighbors and we have new
leadership there now
and um
we see them as really a kind of conduit
for bringing in
artists which has been
sorely lacking in our past
it's also the home of the harvard film
archive which is one of the great film
repositories in the country we've just
built a brand new 300-seat theater that
will have you know the most
sophisticated projection system on
campus so all of a sudden now
we never we never had a seat at the
table before but now we can actually be
a player in terms of moving image so
um
what has always been driving us from the
beginning is harvard has like all a lot
of your universities we have great
collection resources and why aren't they
talking together why aren't they working
together and
i i suspect that
the movement and the directions that
harvard takes will not necessarily be
the ones that others have taken in large
part because in some ways we're coming
late to the game so we can't simply
duplicate what's already there
someone else i have a question oh go
ahead
sorry
brian wallace bryn mawr college i'd love
to have your president back to the
campus to help articulate the role that
the visual arts can play on a campus at
bryn mawr
my question is about
alums and graduates of programs and how
to given the changes in the institutions
that we've been talking about these past
few days how we can remain engaged with
recent graduates our own recent work
study and other student workers and
longer term how we can remain engaged
with alums
from from prior decades as resources
for
students as emerging professionals
and as resources for our own collecting
um and more generally stewardship
activities we have very complicated
relationships with our development
departments advancement departments
offices of alumni affairs this is an
area that's sort of
important tectonically in this in the
same register perhaps as as the the
groups that max mentioned a minute ago
yeah well let me take that quickly at
the first to say that you know these
university colleges are all good at
doing these sort of grand overall class
reunions but what they've discovered
over time is that some of the most
intense engagement that comes when you
bring people back around their central
life and professional interests
and so you know 10 years after doing the
starting the gallery guide program with
ellen albert who's here and others you
know you invite those students to come
back you create many reunions of the
people who've had life-changing
uh situations happen in their education
with the institution and that means we
have to devote resources to doing that
we have to find members of our board and
people who think you know not only is it
nice to fund an exhibition or to fund a
publication but this generation of you
know new people who we want to keep
involved that it takes time and
resources to keep them together just as
we're finding the value of a you know
group of us here today that
we have to spend the time and the money
to make it happen and so i think it's
it's a great question and it's one we
ought to all ask ourselves because
otherwise people do tend to drift away
and get involved in other things and we
all deal with cultivation boy all of us
up here you know are stewarding
relationships all the time as part of
our jobs but you can do little things i
mean one thing that we did at dartmouth
was
we're very proud of our space for
dialogue program which is a
10 hour a week paid internship and at
the end of your year it's kind of your
culminating experience as a senior you
get to do an exhibition
and close to 100 students have been
through that program and so what we
decided to do recently was to offer them
free membership of the museum
and all we asked for in return was that
they answer a couple of questions kind
of where are you now you know what was
what was meaningful about that
experience you know and so in a way it
would it allowed us to to think about
how those uh space for dialogue
experiences could be better but also
we're tracking them and we know
the famous alarms like you know max
anderson at dallas and george
shackleford of the kimball you know we
we know
those alums but we've also found that
there are a lot of
dartmouth alums i would say especially
after the founding of the hood in 1985
who've gone on to museum careers
and they're often out there as associate
curators in the midwest or or assistant
curators at the guggenheim
and so we've started with our uh
quarterly newsletter to just have a sort
of alumni voice where we can bring in
those museum professionals
and trisha pake you know recently did a
piece on ellsworth kelly and it was
really wonderful and i think i think
those little things can help you so that
when you they do come to the 25th
reunion
it's not like they're seeing you again
for the first time and saying wow this
place has changed they're actually
actively engaged and that goes back to
your point is is that if you can engage
sustained in a sustained way over many
years they're going to be at your
ambassadors your advocates they actually
might be the ones who meet the president
and say boy you've got a great museum
you better support it
and and tell some of the best when they
leave that you expect them to want to be
board members in 10 or 15 years that's
right
what i'd add to that is in my experience
the thing that really pulls people back
is engagement with students again
maybe it's because they're reminded of
their lives before all their hopes and
dreams were obliterated but yes but i'm
joking but i think you mean the bad john
walsh and the good
job but we we work hard uh to involve
students in virtually anything we do
that involves you know our visiting
committee our alumni the board of
overseers the corporation because
you know it's it's it's a very powerful
thing it really is i think um
the student
is what keeps them involved i think
there's another aspect to it and i hear
this often from alums who are involved
in their civic museums and their
community it's the idea that we're about
learning and they're they're them coming
back and having an opportunity to
continue learning so i think that
um remembering that you know that that
moment of transformation doesn't end
when you finish
your degree and in fact you can play the
role of of them always being your
student and i think
no more time you invite them back and
don't just give them information about
what you're doing but allow them to
participate in that kind of ongoing
education is really
key right and helpful
okay i think we have time for me two
questions maybe three and then
my eager staff members want to keep this
thing on the clock i know that if i if i
could just add to that this is just like
a sack i'm here that we also create a
net i'm here um we also allow for the
students who've been especially in the
world gallery teacher program to be a
network for themselves and that they can
be in touch with each other and as each
graduating year leaves they can be in
touch with former ones and mentor with
each other within their own professions
and so that they connect to us but they
connect to each other and that i think
strengthens their desire to be part of
our larger community yeah
great point
someone else yeah
hi hello i'm francesca baver from the
harvard art museums i'm in the division
of academic and public programming and
i just actually wanted to respond to
your earlier question about the
materials lab which tom has already
talked about
i'm i will be responsible for the
programming for that in collaboration
with a lot of my colleagues
and the idea is not so much for us to
provide another space to train makers
but more to integrate um
the making process into the learning and
thinking about art process very much in
sort of following the tradition that was
started by edward forbes at our museum
earlier in the last century of um the
egg and plaster course which was really
giving people you know putting the
art materials in
our audiences and students hands and
giving them a chance to really
link that kinetic experience with
looking
and also that way providing them with
the chance to ask questions about the
making process
and we're hoping to draw on
the many artists who come through not
only the carpenter center but the
university we have over a hundred
visiting artists a year
and really bringing them and other
makers who may be involved with them um
in the collaborative process
and sort of thinking about
process and problem solving and um
sorry about the correctly voice
and also
i mean that's part of it and also maybe
reaching across campus not maybe but
certainly reaching across campus and
trying to collaborate with
um faculty and integrating that into
their teaching process and working with
the collection
and then i wanted to bring up another
thing in connection with digital
tools that we might be thinking about
certainly there's
work being done not only at harvard but
at other universities and thinking about
how digital annotation
might be used as a very powerful
tool for interactive learning
and also
scholarship and sharing ideas i mean if
we think about what's being done already
with um
you know
interpretation of texts
um that we could apply that also to
visual materials and
create this you know worldwide dialogue
from which we as you know museum
staff
and researchers could also learn from
students and from the public and sort of
access
you know the kind of thinking that
people might have about artworks in a
much broader way so
and that requires a lot of um resources
as well because
you know you need servers you need
people who are going to help to curate
that kind of annotation but it just
seems like it would be a very powerful
thing to think about and that we could
share across across university
collections as well
could i ask you a question about that
yeah is the is the
digital production also part of the
materials lab is the materials lab both
physical materials and digital
materials there's there's the idea that
we would also expand to
investigating digital materials but the
interpretive
as part of the interpretive materials
that we're also creating at the museum
we're creating tours digital tours and
one of the things that a number of us
would like to integrate into those
digital tours is this ability to
i think we're talking about mainly
some kind of tablet
some kind of annotation possibility so
that the visitor the students whoever
and professors could be using these two
could um use that as a as a tool for
dialogue
so right
now anyone else out there uh yes um
okay is this on
is this on okay
i'm robert woltersdorf the director of
the bennington museum in bennington
vermont by the way that's a municipal
museum not part of bennington college
which does not have its own museum
but just two weeks ago yesterday we
announced to our community that we were
forging a new partnership with
bennington college
running ahead with that without knowing
just what that means yet
um but one thing i'm really interested
in bennington college has always been a
college interested not in looking back
not at looking at history but in making
and creating
and we've been talking about integrating
university museums with with academic
programs but i'm really interested in um
in the role of the museum not just in
modeling creativity but in
inspiring creativity in being an engine
for creation and actually an engine also
for economic development in a local
community
almost all of you are at schools with
great you know great teaching museums
but with great
making programs architecture schools art
schools drama schools music schools how
are you integrating with them now and
are there new ways that you can do that
new ways different from five or 20 years
ago
i agree with you completely we're really
fortunate to have um great a great
collection for the city and amazing art
history
faculty on campus and
tremendous curators but we also live in
a city in particular it's very much
about creativity great creative programs
visual art programs and in music
programs one of the things that we've
done is really
austin's known for its you know music
it's known for creativity broadly we
have a very strong music program for
example where we invite faculty from the
music school or also musicians in the
community
to work with
in our galleries
they perform they sometimes write pieces
sometimes perform in response to works
of art in the galleries
we've had conversations between
people of different disciplines we've
even brought in different disciplines
into the museum right now we have an
exhibition looking at deborah hayes work
a renowned choreographer and
allowing our visitors to understand
choreography and sense of perception and
how they how you view a dancer in a
museum space which is a very different
experience than sitting in an audience
with a performer on stage
it it matters because it does i think
give a sense of
creativity and that kind of broad
curiosity again that i think is really
important that i want the museum to
instill in our visitors and the artists
in those
the art feature art historians and just
you know anybody that's on that campus
um and i do think that interdisciplinary
approach um to looking at our work is
important for us
and i would just like to address the
other side of your question which was
how can
the college or university arm museum be
part of the economic growth of the
community and waterville is a
post-industrial economically depressed
town and if we've
as we've thought about changing our
profile
it's been incredibly important to us to
be part of local arts and economic
initiatives that are re that are
rethinking the profile of waterville at
large so it's important for us to be
part of initiatives in the community to
make it an affordable space for artists
to live and work
as we are bringing people who are
interested about art to waterville
we also want to be giving back in a way
so i think you're pointing to a really
important part of our mission that we
don't always fully consider how can we
be part of the economy of our
local community in a way that's not just
about bringing artists into our doors
and into the the creativity that happens
in our spaces but how can it be
happening in our larger community it's
extremely important to our thinking yeah
let me just expand on that briefly to
say that there's been a 600 student high
school magnet art school built within
two blocks of the art gallery at which
the trisha brown performances you saw
some of were performed in that high
school two weeks ago and there's a major
junior college three and a half blocks
from here those were
construction projects that came out of a
dialogue between yale and the downtown
arts area where we wanted students to
not have to sign up for you know bus
trips that would take forever and
permissions to get here those students
now just walk up here
every week often for classes much in the
way our students come from the yale
campus so this gets into this other
notion that we have to be in dialogue
with our university leaders but many of
us should know our mayors our councilmen
our political figures the major business
people in our communities they all have
an interest in raising particularly the
the quality of public education which is
in real jeopardy in our country and all
kinds of social and other problems that
we we could talk another whole
conference about i think i need to end
this now we're gone five minutes over
but pam do you want to say any
concluding remarks
i want to just commend you and your team
for putting this fantastic thing
together
up there
get up there
i really just want to say thank you all
so much for taking three days to be here
and these fantastic conversations and i
hope they'll continue and thank you